hey you guys it's Friday again I hope
everybody had a really good Merry
Christmas
this is the first show that we're
recording after our Christmas special
hope everybody like the Christmas
special but anyway alright so this is
kind of relating to our last movie
because we did the Christmas Chronicles
which was a Kurt Russell movie this is
also a Kurt Russell movie right more of
an action character study type of movie
yeah I mentioned it a couple times on
the show before it's one of my favorite
movies probably the most underrated
movies in my opinion you know I think
the thing gets a bum rap I think a lot
of people misunderstand the movie I mean
Oliver Harper did a really good review
of this movie and he liked it but he
didn't mention a lot of the things that
this movie gets into a lot a lot of the
subtext and I think it has to do with
the fact that Harper is an event isn't a
veteran and a lot of this stuff whoever
wrote this story they must have
consulted with some guys that actually
served in infantry units or special
forces type units because it talks a lot
about a lot of the the issues that
soldiers go through yeah and that's one
of the reason why I love this movie and
one and what happens like when they have
to integrate back into a society yeah
it's about getting out of the service
that's basically motors it yeah and what
to do with the training and the
conditioning you were given by these
institutions yeah because it does change
you it does yeah I think that's a good
way yeah and it talks about you know it
even touches on issues like PTSD in the
civilian world PTSD you know would be
considered to be kind of like a like a
handicap but in a military situation
PTSD is like an advantage yeah you know
me that that would keep you alive well
you can keep it under control you know
yeah well I mean like I said that's kind
of the point of the movie is that you
know this character he's almost like I
don't want to call him a tragic
character but he's a character that
through circumstances that were out of
his control is pretty much programmed to
be a particular way and once he there's
no longer any use for him and he has to
like live in a regular civilization he
has a really hard time adapting to that
and kind of how that happens
yeah even though if we didn't mention
that the movies called soldier it came
out in 1998 and stars Kurt Russell in a
largely non-speaking role he only has a
few lines in this yeah and there's a
reason for that some people kind of
criticized it well he doesn't have much
speaking what set it tells you right
there in the story when he was in
military academy when they were
selecting their soldiers that the
subliminal messaging that they were
pumping into the kids you know through
this loudspeakers there's little
speakers in the background was that a
soldier does not speak until he has
spoken to by a superior officer right
and he doesn't speak until he's spoken
to by somebody yeah by somebody who is
possibly a superior even even there even
to speak much between peers yeah it's
pretty much like I said um this movie it
was actually directed by Paul WS
Anderson I think his name he also did
mortal combat alien vs predator some
other movies like that Resident Evil he
did the Resident Evil series it was
actually written by David peoples who
was a co-writer on the script for the
original Blade Runner he also wrote the
script for Unforgiven and the
interesting thing about this movie is
that it's almost he you know the writer
has said that this is like it's a Blade
Runner spell Blade Runner spin-off
there's not also a Liam
yeah there's but he's like it's he's
it's set in the same universe he said
pretty much there's supposedly he you
know when Kurt Russell goes to this like
you know essentially waste disposal
planet they're supposed to be like a
spinner in the junkyard somewhere yeah
although I haven't seen it well there's
there's a lot more hints than that if
the tattoo tattoo yeah and also if you
freeze frame sergeant Todd that's who
currently that's who Kurt Russell plays
be freeze frame sergeant Todd's military
records it says that he fought at
Tannhauser gate yeah and and he also
fought the shoulder of Orion yep which
these were things that right bad he
talked about in his and Blade Runner
also I looked at what he was awarded and
he he was awarded a lot of medals and
one of the medals that he was awarded
was the patch of Plissken
okay yeah so escape from New York is
also in this universe alright so is it's
pretty cool and if you looked at his
statistics his strength was like ninety
nine thousand two hundred and something
his dexterity was like nine thousand one
hundred and something his intelligence
was like seven thousand something but
his charisma was like two hundred yeah
so he had no charisma of his own he was
just high-performance which that they
kind of get into that later on you know
they were not designed to integrate with
regular people
now this is not that the United States
Army that we're talking about who's
created this guy this is some kind of
corporation that is a contract and with
I guess whatever runs the United States
or whatever runs America at this point
yeah because it's a futuristic yeah it
the banner that they're training under
is just says American forces in English
and then it says forces americanus in
Spanish which is American forces so
that's who this is and they were
selected from birth the baby's ever
crying the loudest they put a little tag
on him said one a and they were taken
away from the rest of the babies now the
nurse that was doing this didn't look
too happy about it I'm assuming that the
babies that were not selected were
killed I don't know if these were
natural birth babies you think we really
get into that because like Blade Runner
this kind of goes into a lot of issues
of genetically enhanced yeah humans but
I'm not sure like I always got the
impression that the generation that Kurt
Russell's you know soldier comes from I
mean he's about 40 years old in this
story and it's kind of a thing where
that were his you know type of soldiers
on the wane yes been replaced so I
thought that the implication was that
they that these were simply human babies
yeah that were selected for their
particular aggression or loudness or
whatever and then they were taken away
yeah and pretty much brainwashed you
know essential
well-conditioned missionary so let's
talk about no loss of empathy you know
training not to speak unless spoken to
to be obedient to be loyal I think they
were test-tube babies they may have I
don't think they had mothers they were
all the same age and they were all just
kind of mass-produced and they selected
the ones that they wanted and through
the other ones away remember because
there was stuff about they were trying
to avoid paperwork and try to avoid
attention to what they were doing right
so this was not a something that was
happening in public and they were
training the kids in secret and there
was constant subliminal programming you
hear him say the the the thus
eliminating that they were given was
saying things like soldiers do not need
friends and family because your unit is
your family and your unit's friend is
warfare so that's their trying to
integrate them all into just one kind of
unit of selfless service they're not
individuals really they're just they're
collectivist yeah and you find out a lot
of stuff that they had done to them
later on you know as the movie unfolds
when he starts when Todd gets out of
service and finally has to deal with
families because you find out certain
that he well the only thing he knew
about families is that he had killed
some soldiers one time and the soldiers
the enemy soldiers he was killing had
were mowing down families but when he
killed those soldiers he didn't do it to
save the families he just did it to kill
the soldiers he didn't have any
compassion for the surviving family
members now that changes later on in the
movie when he makes a connection with
the with these families that he runs
into and he decides to kill the soldiers
not to kill the enemy soldiers but to
protect the families right so his
motivations had changed halfway about
towards the end of the movie but it's
pretty cool Flik
you know the military account you also
find out later on that when Todd was
about third
tene he had killed a classmate to
achieve dominance in in in in in in the
in in his class of soldiers so there was
a hierarchy and they fought to reach the
the levels that the command levels that
they were that they fell into he had
something like a friend it was a black
guy named Riley and whenever they show
Todd as a child
Riley's always with him and later on
when Riley things Todd gets killed I'm
kind of getting ahead of myself but when
when Riley thinks Todd gets killed Riley
was affected by it you know I show a
zoom in on his face and he becomes in
charge of the soldier group but I'm kind
of getting ahead of myself um I don't
know well I think kind of the
interesting thing about this movie too
like I said that you know it didn't get
great reviews when it came out it's
actually a critical failure it cost
about fifty sixty million dollars to
make and only made back about fourteen
million in the theaters and it was
actually only released you know direct
to DVD in Europe and other places so I
don't know if it actually ended up
making its budget back even but the
interesting thing about it is like you
like you said there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on in this yeah that people aren't
seeing yeah it's like Kurt Russell it's
more like I said it's more character
study than a than an action movie and it
also has some interesting things to say
about nature versus nurture very much
because you know Kurt Russell's
generation of soldiers who were assuming
are fully human but are simply taken
away at birth and are just you know
conditioned into a particular lifestyle
and then you know when the movie starts
you see that there's now a new
generation who have been completely
genetically engineered and supposedly
you know and are they've been tweaked
yeah and our better soldiers in every
way they are faster they're stronger
they are less empathetic you know they
have no feelings their emotions and
stuff like that so but the interesting
thing is that over the course of the
story and Kurt Russell's character after
he is you know essentially discarded you
know in service for these new soldiers
to come in him almost like developing
humanity but it's not really developing
humanity because
had it all right it just goes to show
that you can't suppress it no matter how
much you condition the Apple which is
why the corporation wanted to
genetically engineer people that
couldn't feel anything another thing
that's kind of left out in the reviews
the reviews are always talking about
well there's no character development in
time there is a lot of care to develop
there is there he's not speaking yeah
what happens is they show you his
flashbacks and they show you his
memories and they show you what he's
looking at and you've got to do it
you've got to put it piece it together
yourself and really I think having
military service kind of helps you
because we you know guys that serve that
automatically understand what the issues
are that they're talking about yeah but
one of the good things one of the good
characters in the movie that you know a
lot of people don't mention is Gary
Busey's in it yeah and normally he plays
kind of like a psycho but in this he
actually plays a good guy yeah he's like
the voice of reason yeah he's he's
Todd's captain captain Church the
captain church isn't wasn't bred and
born as soldiers but he just commanded
them he's just a regular guy regular
soldier whose dad was him was also in
the military as a maintenance officer
and you know church had seen combat and
he works for this same company and you
know he's he's grown to like respect
these super soldiers that they created
you know and he likes Todd even though
they kind of handle these guys kind of
like trying to tag dogs they don't get
close to him on a personal level they
just kind of command them and you know
from you know they're in the same room
on them but they kind of keep emotional
distance from them because they're
they're kind of inserting they're
expensive but they're also expendable
and you don't want to get involved with
their conditioning because they're
conditioned to be you know not
empathetic because you know that's how
if a unit can doesn't have empathy it
can take a lot of casualties and
continue going because they're not
really helping the other guys you know
the best way to help them is win a
battle yeah you know that's that's
that's really how you know you tend to
look at it and really good infantry type
units and special force all the depends
on the situation now
well church
he has to deal with this carnal that
shows up and then the kernel that shows
up his name is
I think mica mica mica mica Mia and he's
wearing kind of a gray uniform which
kind of makes me think that he's kind of
like part of an intelligence outfit in a
higher echelon and he shows up and in
his grey uniform he's a colonel he's got
new soldiers and these these guys are
just genetically tweaked out super
soldiers they can they work out like
crazy they're faster they never get
tired they don't ever get tired they
don't have any kind they're almost
robotic they don't have any compassion
at all and church he doesn't he doesn't
believe in this he's like yeah but my
guys are battle tested and they're
creative and basically what church is
talking about as my guys are honorable
yeah
because later on when man kind of
getting ahead of myself cuz a lot
happens in the story later on Meachem
decides to actually be tray and just
abandon all the old soldiers and leave
him on a planet to die including Todd
and I think he thought Todd was dead
though he he just got dumped on the
garbage planet with the other dead
soldiers that were killed during the
fight between right the superior
quote-unquote soldiers and the old
soldiers yeah and Captain Church you
know Gary Busey he does a great job okay
that's it I've had I've had enough of
your West Point ass you know and he
rebels against the colonel the colonel
shoots and kills him yeah and eventually
towards the end
the Colonel's gotta answer to Todd
eventually which is kind of this theme
of where sometimes in the military the
guys that wars are always kind of like
rich men's Wars and poor men or fight no
okay yeah and a lot of soldiers are
being trained it's kind of to fight
these battles and they're not really
fighting their own Wars they're fighting
somebody else's war so and many times
these guys at the top are kind of paper
pushers and when you're talking about
pure honor and ability they don't quite
stack up to some of these guys who are
they're in the trenches fighting and
that's that was the that was kind of the
theme for that scene of what Todd did to
the colonel well because I mean in the
whole thing to is that one of the you
know the character arc of Kurt Russell's
character you know Todd is that he
discovers that he can fight for
something like yeah something honorable
and for something important and
meaningful rather than just killing
people right because somebody because
someone told you did yeah cuz somebody
told you to they were being trained to
do things kind of dispassionately yeah
okay just go here you're ordered to do
it yeah these people do this and you did
and to be kind of emotional about it
later on he evolved to fight his own
Wars take to protect the people he cares
about
not just to kill people but based on
orders and how the movie ends is pretty
important to the entire story arc
because Todd all right when Todd was
thrown away like garbage on the garbage
planet his surviving unit was disarmed
and they were just turned into regular
workers and they were kind of like the
servants to the new soldiers they
weren't allowed to have weapons later on
and one of the little missions they were
told him that they had to set up this
sensor array and Riley goes are we gonna
get issued weapons you guys no no only
soldiers get weapons and he salute he
says yes sir and he goes you don't have
to salute you're not a soldier anymore
and you could just see that you know the
the humiliation where they went from
having a purpose to not really having a
purpose anymore at the end of the movie
Todd rescues the family scavengers that
he'd that adopted him and he rescues his
old unit they rebel against the
corporation that they worked for and
they steal the ship and escape that
garbage planet to go to the Trinity
moons where those garbage people are
originally trying that's what they were
trying to go there they crash-landed and
so they had to kind of eCos a you know
inca society out of this big garbage
pile right so he tries to get them to
where they're going to the Trinity moon
to start a new colony yeah and by this
time Todd has been a
has adopted a family who had lost the
the father the father yeah okay now what
they're talking about what this what
this story is talking about when that
element of the story is their content
about the lifecycle
you know creatures and human beings and
animals have life cycles and nations
kind of have life cycles to the nations
that that Todd was servant as the same
one that of you know Blade Runner and
alien it's kind of taken over by
corporations it's kind of towards the
end of its life well Todd and his group
you know a group of soldiers and the
group of scavengers are going to new
world to start a new society
to start a new civilization so it's the
beginning of the birth cycle again and a
lot of times if you look at history
that's kind of what happens yeah
surviving soldiers from some kind of
apocalypse or something rebel and they
go cut out carve out their own existence
in a new land you know and that's what
they're talking about there it's a good
part that's a good way to end the story
in the movie if you ask me he becomes
one of the founding fathers of a new
colony yeah yeah and like I said I think
it's good too because you know when he
has to fight like I said for the
scavengers and like the people that he
has come to care about who is you know
his adopted family and extended family
it also helps him his humanity like
helps him fight the corporations because
he basically goes into guerrilla warfare
he can do like creative things where you
know the may be more robotic soldiers
kind of a lot of things in a particular
way and that went back to into the
nature versus nurture aspect of the
movie when when he's went when Todd was
back in military school he's like seven
or eight years old one of the things
that they would show him is a pack of
dogs and a wild boar fighting to show
them that the pack of the pack of dogs
could beat a wild boar yeah so fighting
as a team all right it's always better
than fighting as an individual even if
you're strong okay but it's also talking
about the straw
for life in the struggle for existence
now right nature that nature is kill or
be killed and that was the theme of
their upbringing kill or be killed so to
solve this problem of kill or be killed
how do you do it are these soldiers
nurtured or are they born so in other
words there's a difference between being
created or born great or being created
great through a process now let's say
like training and experience right and
the movie definitely falls on the side
that it's better to be nurtured in other
words experience battle experience honor
you know that it's not something that
comes about just through genetic
manipulation
you know it's saying that soldiers
aren't born soldiers are created just or
all people great people are not born
great people are created that's another
way to look at it and that's the theme
they're talking about you know dig the
new guys the new soldiers were good but
they got defeated a lot and they did
dumb stuff because they didn't have any
experience they didn't have any honor
yeah they didn't rigid in their own it
seemed play and they weren't created
slowly and nurtured by an environment
and leadership and you know in
relationships between commanders and
people you know they were just kind of
like shake and bake yeah shaken bake
shaken bake super soldier doesn't work
that's what they were talking about well
yeah that's kind of the interesting
conundrum going on in this movie it's
just like you know it is it really good
to have all of these you know
essentially drones are just you know
dude that don't feel any they don't have
any feelings they don't have any
personal empathy it's like I I feel like
a lot of times that scene and
particularly by the corporation in this
movie empathy and compassion is seen as
a weakness but it's really not in a lot
of situations and I feel like this movie
kind of you know focused on that a
little bit in in the situation that Todd
and his
we're in I I think they did a pretty
good job of equipping them for what they
were being asked to do yes which is they
sent him out to random places where they
didn't know anybody there just kill
enemy soldiers you know yeah and to do
it you know dispassionately because you
don't know either side it's not your job
to know either side the color the
corporation is telling you to do it yeah
yeah so you shouldn't get they didn't
want them emotionally involved in it
they didn't want any kind of emotional
impact on them of seeing people killed
right so that's how they did it they
just you know that your unit is your
family and Warfare's your friend just
keep it simple that's what they were
doing
yeah and don't get involved with it yeah
but there's a lot of cool callback a lot
of cool callbacks in the movie I mean in
one in one scene they kind of quickly
show in the beginning Colonel Todd's
excuse me uh Sergeant Todd's military
career some of the battles he fought in
one of them was on the Argentine moons
that's what they that's right and if you
looked at the spacesuit he was wearing
they're fighting on a moon in a space
it's the same spacesuit pretty much from
alien one to the spacesuits that they
use that there's a bunch of alien stuff
and a bunch of stuff from Glade I'm not
super blatant but there's like a lot of
I would call them Easter eggs I suppose
yeah I mean even though I don't think
it's you know it's not a secret that the
writer wanted this to be in the same
universe yeah but they don't whack you
over the head with it is yeah a couple
little reference and also the same
universe as uh Escape from New York I
didn't notice that yeah he got the patch
cuz I've seen this two or three times
but I did not notice got the patch of
Plissken I haven't noticed the spinner
yet either it's in there some I've heard
that it's in like the first half of the
movie but I can't yes I mean because you
know he's sent to this planet called
Arcadia
some of those have yours at that of it
and it was it's a waste disposal planets
but it essentially just a giant planet
sized junkyard and supposedly there's a
spinner in there but I haven't seen it
but there is so much junk and it's also
a desert yeah and there's some scenes of
planes broken up planes in a desert with
propellers and wings set up and they
were all living inside of it in the
desert
yeah just like out of the Mad Max video
game oh yeah
where they were using the propellers to
generate wind electricity yeah so you
just see a lot of Easter eggs from a
bunch of other movies in it
yeah good like I said I don't they don't
hit you over the head with it like look
it's like Mad Max or hey look it's like
alien it's just like it's very subtle
and it's usually just like in a little
flashback or something like that and
like I said I love the detail about his
tattoos about like all the battles he
had fought in yeah so like if you saw
Blade Runner you'd be like oh yeah there
were another battery yeah that's like
pretty funny so it kind of like expands
it to a larger yes so there are
replicants and Androids in there
somewhere
yeah because you know this is a Blade
Runner and alien yeah and another thing
that another thing about the movie is
that I said I have it I had the blu-ray
the blu-ray is really good I watched it
on my TV I think it maxes out at about
10 8 10 8 TV and our bedroom is yeah
looks good yeah it looks good but it
doesn't look good in very super high
definition you can see that these are
boring yeah on our big TV man with that
motion smoothing kind of feel to it it
looks weird it looks like an old BBC
Doctor Who I think it's moving off
though can you
yeah it didn't look good and also if if
it's super high like 4k style television
you can tell that the sets are made out
of plastic yeah and the CG looks
terrible but in lower resolution where
it's supposed to the movie's supposed to
look very soft yeah it looks about as
good is uh I don't know alien 3 that was
the thing it's like so weird we watched
it a time or two like on the TV in our
room and then we had friends over and we
watched it in the living room yeah I
look crazy and it looked yeah because
the one of the TV in the living room is
like way higher definition yeah one in
our room is and so I was like wow this
is very strange looking and I couldn't
like like you said it looked like a set
look I guess it was yet well because see
initially I think the film was actually
supposed to be filmed on-location but
because with the locations where they're
gonna film it they flooded out or there
was like some kind of horrible weather
disaster and they couldn't do it there
so they ended up having to fill most of
it on sets and when you see it like in
slightly lower
Ellucian you can't tell it looks you
know like it's outside but when you see
it on super high definition like you
said it looks like a doctor who happens
a doctor like it looks like a like an
older TV and it looks like they're
sitting on a stage yeah yeah you want to
see it in low I never saw any
definitions really weird because I guess
movies nowadays you know cuz this is
from 1998 so it's like you know that's
20 years ago yeah so you know movies
they make nowadays they're more tuned
into like how people are going to be
watching them so they try to make them
you know so they look really good in
high definition but it's like they
weren't really thinking about that in
1998 know they didn't know people were
gonna have [ __ ] they didn't know HD
was cuz TVs that you could see every
[ __ ] Poron people crustle looks really
good in it yeah we spent a long time
getting into shape 18 it shows he
trained for 18 months he's he's probably
in the top shape and I came is almost 50
yeah I think he was 47 what do you think
was 49 I saw 47 maybe some of the other
one said yeah he's pushing 50 in it but
he doesn't look it also this was on the
Wikipedia page actually very early in
the filming he broke his ankle during
one of the stunts and so they basically
had to film all the [ __ ] of him like
being sick and like laying down or
sitting and stuff they to film all that
first until the ankle healed and then
later on they had to do the standing
[ __ ] her that's the the guns have aged
well for you guys that are into guns you
see stuff like Claridge on
nine-millimeter Claridge Hitec carbines
I haven't seen those in forever but I
think they used some of those in Total
Recall ache a long long barreled aks
like our PK's in a bullpup kits with
like two bayonets and optics you know
red dots with flashlights on them you
know neat gun stars the bad guys kind of
look like the hawk Conan's black body
armor masks you know gas masks
mini guns flamethrowers rocket launchers
a lot of cool guns make an appearance in
it yeah they're dressed up most of them
some of them are stock you know although
like I said this is I
the reason why maybe this didn't do very
well at the theater one because I think
they tried to market it toward teenagers
which was kind of strange and I think
they also kind of tried to market it as
a straight-up action flick which it's
really not there's a lot of action set
uses and battles and [ __ ] like that in
it but most of it is a character it's
based on you know Kurt Russell's
character kind of his character arc and
how he kind of develops a sense of
humanity and things yeah it's more of a
mythology yeah it has action in it but
it's a mythology similar to Conan in a
way yeah so I think it was more failure
of marketing then yeah you know then any
weakness on the film's part because I
think this is actually I really liked it
and I don't usually like I'm not a huge
action movie fan I like some of them but
I really like this one because it seemed
like the story had some depth the
characters have some depth and it had
like an interesting mythology building
and interesting message to it so I
actually really enjoyed it and I thought
Kurt Russell was great in it even though
he hardly talks yeah he doesn't have to
though that's what I mean he acts a lot
with his face with his eyes and stuff
like that so you can see like what a
good actor he is and if he doesn't have
to sign and in the end when he get when
he goes totally commando to you know to
kill off the the bad guys and save the
scavengers he does some stuff right out
of command with the face paint some of
his one-liners kind of sound uh sound
like stuff that Arnold would say back in
an old Arnold Schwarzenegger action
flick so you know they're doing Easter
eggs to him jumping up out of the water
and killing guys with knives Rambo style
so he's Rambo and commando yeah at the
same time space Rambo space yeah but
yeah definitely I mean if you are into
Blade Runner if you like this good you
like Kurt Russell obviously because you
know Tom has a big man crush I like
gross and if you like Kurt Russell and
you haven't seen it cuz like I said this
one fell way under the radar yeah ever
even heard about it until I actually we
saw the review on Oliver Harper's
channel yeah I never heard Tomatoes the
Rotten Tomatoes the I think it's 12%
yeah 12% but that's that's the critics
yeah the audience score is higher is
like 43 and
it's very polarized you know a lot of
like four and five stars and going man
[ __ ] [ __ ] these critics they don't know
they're telling this is a great movie
there's a lot of that and then there's a
lot of them just kind of in some of them
it's kind of different yeah but you know
I think over time this if this movie
were exposed to more people they really
kind of understood the themes that was
talking about it had been rated a lot
higher yeah because there's a lot more
going on I mean it's a cult classic this
was the same guy that wrote co-wrote
Blade Runner and wrote Unforgiven I mean
yes the classic movies so it's not they
he knew he knows what he knew his doing
right so it's not just like some
throwaway I think that he said act I
mean I think it came out the timing was
strange was late 90s yeah and a lot of
movies like this would people didn't
really different kind of passe in a
certain way the 80s action movie was
very passe and by then Sharan plus it
has a very generic title it does I think
I think that's if it had a sensational
title there means you feel like it was
part of the Blade Runner or alien
universe yes because it even the cover
of it comes across like looking very
more like a yeah like a knockoff like
middle of the rare kind of action movie
which it's really not so like I said I
think that's more a failure of marketing
then yeah then the film they just didn't
have the right poster they didn't have
the right marketing and didn't have the
right box for the damn thing they just
yeah that the title was wrong that
happens a lot like I said I mean because
the people that make movies and we talk
about this all the time in regards like
trailers and things because some takus
you know we go to the movies a lot so we
see a lot of trailers and sometimes
you'll see a trailer and go wow that
looks stupid as hell but then like when
you see the movie you're gonna I was
pretty good the trailer was completely
misleading and I said well the people
that make the movie are not the same
people that make the trailer so making a
trailer is an art form just as much as
making a movie is and sometimes they
[ __ ] it up yeah and I don't think the
trailer from this one was very good and
also during this timing you say soldier
ways that's like Universal Soldier cuz
that was only that's that's what I
thought then you have like GI Jane and a
bunch of you know that's where that [ __ ]
was going on
these little soldier movies most
importnant good yeah so I think had they
named this differently and had different
cover art and had different cover art
and and and sold it as something
differently I think it would have done
might might have benefited by going a
little more art house route maybe not
completely but maybe kind of a mixture
between if there was a way they could
actually gotten annex II know morph in
there or a remnant or something like
yeah up the sci-fi right good is set on
a different planet it's not like you
know it is a sci-fi essentially so they
probably could have ramped that up more
than cuz like I said if I just saw the
cover of this on the shelf and saw the
title I would just pass right on by yeah
it looks like if they did somehow had
the licensing to where you know the same
corporation that made Todd was also
making the colonial Marines or they were
also you know I mean they had some of
those alien eggs or trying to get him or
whaling corporation because that's what
they're talking about it's just that
they're not mentioned in it yeah and
like I said you know and if we could go
20 years back in time and be in the
marketing department for this movie we
could go better because yeah they really
focused on the wrong thing in the
marketing campaign but that happens a
lot you know yeah but and sometimes it
takes a long time like for a movie to
find its audience which happened with
Blade Runner it happened with I'm
speaking of Kurt Russell happen with the
thing also yeah so you know what are you
gonna do nothing that's what
but yeah so go check out soldier from
1998 if you like that kind of thing and
if you like Kurt Russell and if you
haven't seen it like I said it's pretty
underrated night I actually quite
enjoyed it and that will do it for our
latest movie retrospective and remember
if you like the show to like share
subscribe if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
oh also remember my book faceless
villain volume 2 is finally finally out
of an audiobook it is up it is on
audible sound like crazy um yeah it's
like I was amazed how many cons like so
him a day in the first day I was like I
was like is that right my kids because I
checked this
figures everyone kind of like that but
yeah it should be up on iTunes in a day
or two it usually once it appears on
audible and Amazon it usually takes you
know two or three days for it to come up
on iTunes and other platforms so look
out for it on there and if you liked the
book remember write a review it does
actually really help a lot and remember
if you like our movie retrospectives
like this one right here they come out
every Friday our 13 o'clock matinee
which is three new movies in the theater
comes out of here Sunday and our regular
episodes are out every Tuesday so check
them out and we will see you next time
bye